Speaker 1: So for some strange reason,
Republicans cannot seem to get away from proposing
Speaker 2: quack cures
Speaker 1: and treatments and
preventions for COVID that are actually nothing of
the sort. And our latest participant is Republican
Senator Ron Johnson. This is a sitting senator.
This is someone in the U.S. Senate, the greatest,
what do they call it, the greatest deliberative
body in the United States in the world? Who knows?
Speaker 2: He is saying gargle
with mouthwash and even mouthwash.
Speaker 1: Companies are
saying gargle with mouthwash if
Speaker 2: you want, but it
Speaker 1: doesn't do anything as far as
COVID is concerned. And this took place during a
Speaker 2: recent tele town
Speaker 1: hall that he did on Wednesday.
And he said it's been proven that mouthwash
can kill the coronavirus. And as usual, the devil
is sort of in the details. They often start with
a grain of a kernel of a seed of something
that has some connection to reality.
They expand it. And of course, in the background
is the idea that they say, and because these
things exist, you don't really need to go and
get vaccinated. So let's take a look at the clip.
Listen to it, then we'll talk about it.
Speaker 3: But there are things you can
do in vitamin D. You know, zinc to keep yourself
healthy. Vitamin C, by the way, a standard garden
mouthwash that has been proven to kill the
coronavirus. So you need to get it if you,
you know you may reduce viral replication.
All you want to try all these things. It just
boggles my mind that the NIH continues to help
people do nothing. You know, maybe take Tylenol.
Speaker 1: So notice, by the way, that not
only does Ron Johnson mention mouthwash there,
he mentions vitamin D. He mentions zinc and
he mentions vitamin C. So we're going to we're
going to look at each of these one by one.
They they start with like a grain of truth,
a kernel of truth. And so what that could be
Speaker 2: here is that if you take a
Speaker 1: petri dish and you put in viral
droplets of coronavirus and you pour mouthwash
Speaker 2: on them,
Speaker 1: often
mouthwash with high alcohol content,
Speaker 2: does it quote kill the virus?
Speaker 1: It almost certainly happens.
And that can happen when you pour a whole
bunch of different things in a petri
dish onto viral droplets. The problem
Speaker 2: is that
Speaker 1: when you have the virus,
it's in your breathing system, it's in the nasal
Speaker 2: area, it's in the lungs,
etc. So in some very literal sense,
Speaker 1: mouthwash kills the virus
when you gargle. OK, and this goes back to Lysol
does too, and you inject bleach and all this stuff
Speaker 2: just because on some
Speaker 1: fundamental level,
with direct exposure, it kills the
virus. You're not preventing infection
Speaker 2: from the virus. If it's in your
Speaker 1: body, you gargle. You may be killed
whatever is in your mouth, maybe, and then
you breathe and then there's more and it's
in your nasal cavity, et cetera, et cetera. And
Listerine actually put out a statement saying
Listerine does not prevent COVID.
Listerine does not treat COVID,
do not use it, thinking that it
Speaker 2: would do anything at all,
period. Then Ron Johnson mentions the
Speaker 1: vitamin D and the zinc and the
vitamin C. So let's talk about those because
those have also been studied. And again,
there is nothing here. It's we have
something that works and it's the vaccine.
And against earlier variants, it was very good at
preventing infection and hospitalization and death
Speaker 2: against the newer
Speaker 1: Omicron variant. If you
only have two doses, it's less good at preventing
infection. Three seems to be better still very
good at preventing serious illness and death.
Speaker 2: Big picture, statistically,
Speaker 1: is what we know right now. So let's go
through his list. You've got vitamin D. Vitamin D
is something that has been looked at extensively
from the beginning. It's an important thing to
look at. There is an association between higher
vitamin D and, generally speaking, less serious
Speaker 2: or less COVID.
Speaker 1: In general,
Speaker 2: having a good vitamin
Speaker 1: D level, which now is
considered to be above 30. I forget
Speaker 2: what it is micrograms per
Speaker 1: liter or, you know, whatever,
whatever the measurement is, over 30,
and that's just generally good for
Speaker 2: fighting things off. It's not
Speaker 1: clear there's anything
specific to COVID about vitamin D.
It's not clear that taking a vitamin D
Speaker 2: supplement helps prevent
Speaker 1: COVID. And in fact,
Speaker 2: when they look at people
Speaker 1: hospitalized
Speaker 2: with COVID and
Speaker 1: check vitamin D levels and
they say on average they're lower,
it's not even clear whether that's causation
Speaker 2: correlation
Speaker 1: or reverse causation. Meaning Are
you in the hospital because you had a lower
vitamin D level? Or did having a serious case of
COVID lowered the vitamin D level? That's another
question that is that is being asked.
Speaker 2: So generally speaking,
is it good to have a.
Speaker 1: An above 30 vitamin D level,
yes. Is it good specifically because of
COVID? No, it's just a general thing.
Speaker 2: Zinc, zinc and
vitamin D have been studied.
Speaker 1: Sorry, vitamin C,
Speaker 2: there are a ton
Speaker 1: a ton a ton
Speaker 2: of trials on this
Speaker 1: and one very good one did for groups.
Speaker 2: You had a group that received
Speaker 1: only the standard of care at the
time for COVID. Remember, you don't compare
it to nothing. You compare any intervention to
what is the standard. At this point in time,
you get Group one with the standard of care.
Group two got zinc, Group three got vitamin C
Speaker 2: and Group four got zinc and vitamin
Speaker 1: C in the form of ascorbic acid.
Speaker 2: No difference, no
difference. There was two hundred and
Speaker 1: fourteen patients with
Speaker 2: confirmed COVID
Speaker 1: receiving outpatient care, no
difference in how long the symptoms last or
Speaker 2: the likelihood of of ending up
Speaker 1: hospitalized. That's one study,
and there's many others. So all of this goes
to what it goes to. He's recommending all
sorts of different things, including
Speaker 2: things that are within the
Speaker 1: medical realm, but have been studied
and don't seem to actually change outcomes
things like gargling with mouthwash,
Speaker 2: which is close to the
Speaker 1: inject bleach. I mean, it's the same
concept, right? It's the mouthwash kills it.
Speaker 2: When we know
Speaker 1: we have something that
works and is FDA approved fully, that's the Pfizer
vaccine we have via emergency use authorization,
the monoclonal antibodies, which are better
than placebo. But it's still no panacea
Speaker 2: as as we learned.
Speaker 1: But that's not what he's
talking about. Instead, he's talking about all
of these other things. It's not only ignorant,
it's also dangerous because a lot of people
here and they go, look at all these treatments
we have. If you look at them one by one, you see,
these really aren't actually treatments for COVID